previously we did a a sort of tour of
the art we note you know board just went
round and said what the various
components do now we're going to write a
schedule program so that's the code
that's going to run on the chip to turn
our outputs on and off or whatever we're
just going to write one that's going to
turn the LED is on pin 13 on then off
then on then off that's sort of the
hello world equivalent in the
electronics world you can't write hello
world to the screen so you're blinking
LED it's pretty much the first thing you
do when you come to a new environment so
there's a special program called the
arduino ide which stands for integrated
development environment the best way to
think of it is it's like notepad it's a
simple text editor and then a bunch of
other tools that let you program the
Arduino with what you've written so what
you write is just text characters like
in notepad and then it's those special
tools that are also built into the
program that take that text they have to
go through what's called a compilation
stage compile which is taking that text
making the machine code binary code that
actually gets stored on here it has to
make it out on the laptop and then send
it down the USB cable to store it on the
microcontroller whenever you power it or
reset it that code starts running all
those tools are built into this thing
with the Arduino IDE integrated
development environment if you go sir I
think it's Arduino CC you can just
download it they've kept it deliberately
quite simple you can go to much more
complex ones for microcontrollers that
do all sorts of clever things but of
course they've Arduino it's meant to be
simple for beginners for hobbyists for
makers so there's the interface you can
see it is quite clean there's only five
buttons three of those are save open and
new which are in every okay when you
open Arduino you get a sketch
pre-prepared for you so it fills in some
of the blanks for you you've got two
functions that every Arduino sketch
needs to have and they're called setup
and loop and so setup and even gives you
comments which in this language start
with two slashes put your setup code
here to run once the first code that
runs
when you plug power in when you press
reset first lines of code move on what
is the language is it a specific special
language it's a derivative of what the
wiring but ultimately the language you
type into the editor is called C in C++
if people you know that they could just
pick this up yes
the only thing you'd need to learn on
top would be the Arduino code libraries
as well as making the hardware nice and
easy for years I had to think about it
they've made the code buzzing so all the
mocking about dealing with writing to
individual registers in the
microcontroller and making sure that the
timer's are set up correctly all kind of
messy things that you'd normally have to
do is all hidden away so you can just
say turn this pin on and it goes and
does it
one of arches that you'd have to deal
with that and you have to do it for
every different chip so different as we
there's a lot of different chips all of
which needs a slightly different way of
controlling them the code library knows
which you are using and it can do the
right thing for that particular chip
we're going to be using the LED on pin
13 now normally the digital inputs
outputs default to being inputs so
they're reading that's kind of the safe
the safest thing you don't want it
developed into an output suddenly
turning a motor on as soon as you plug
power in there might be dangerous things
like that so the default of being inputs
just reading which is which is safer we
need to tell it hey one wanted to be an
output so we're going to put line code
in here which is pin mode you see that
when you type a keyword in something
that language well it turns it orange or
sometimes blue so that's something that
the IDE gives you as well when you've
typed something correctly goes different
color so you know you've got it right
we're using pin 13 so we tell it 13
comma outputs this should turn blue
which it does and we close the brackets
and put a semicolon so we've told it the
pin mode of 13 to be an output so that's
going to then configure the internal
hardware to pin 13 to drive current put
voltage on that that pin and turn the
LED on or off that's all he's doing the
setup and once it's finished the coding
the setup that one's once
then it goes into loop it once all the
code in loop till it gets to the bottom
and goes back to the top and starts
again and look as it says run repeatedly
forever until you pull power or press
reset so the first thing we want to do
in the loop is turn the LED on that's a
function called digital right we need to
tell you which pin it is in 13 and hi-hi
says put 5 volts on it that's going to
send current flowing through the LED
lighting it up then we need to wait for
a bit of time we can't just turn it off
straight away because that happens in
microseconds and you'll never see it so
we're going to turn it to delay and then
give it a number of microseconds to
delay for so let's delay for 500
microseconds which is half a second then
we need to turn it off I'm going to be
lazy and copy the digital write line
because it's exactly the same and then
just change high to low and then I'm
going to copy the delay line and put it
again there so I've got four lines of
code turn the LED on wave half-second
turn it off wait 5 seconds and it'll go
back and start again now I've done that
the first button up here this tick is
verify all that's going to do is do the
compile stage it's going to check it
make sense is it yes pretty much yeah
it's going to chatter it at least makes
sense logically it may not do what you
want but it's um it's not it's the same
program ezel so it's basically looks
like looking at sentence and saying well
the grammars correcting there's a full
stop at the end yes it could still be
complete gobbling English yeah it's
asking me to save it and sort of save it
and then bring this window up a bit so
the coppola stage it takes your bit of
code it has to combine that with all the
Arduino libraries to form this single
blob of binary data that's going to be
sent down you can see it says done
compiling it gives you a nice bit of
output so it's going to use exactly 1030
bytes so it's just over a kilobyte of
storage space which is 3% total it's
telling me I'm using 9 bytes of dynamic
memory which is 0%
rounded down a good thing on this
particular device there's 32k of memory
for your program and then 2k of lamb
you can put your sophisticated programs
in that amount
so that's done combining so we know that
at least it's it's gonna send down now
we need to tell the arduino ide which
USB port this arduino is connected to
and and what sort of as we know it is so
under tools here we're interested in
board and make sure that Arduino Uno is
selected Arduinos appeared to windows as
serial comport they are USB devices they
appear to be serial devices so it
appears calm ports now is some con 24x
it's self identified as and as we know
you know so we know which one it is
so now we can press this button upload
upload actually compiles again because
you you might have changed your code in
meantime earlier versions of arduino
would compile everything again this just
is a bit better at detecting what's
changed and then upload all you really
see is the TX now x LEDs flickering for
a moment it doesn't take long and then
the early starts blinking
it needs to know a base level to
correctly convert the voltages on these
pins into numbers most of the time I
think
iof is just left up there putting that
knowledge back into the algorithm so the
algorithm can learn from it again and so
sort of reinforcing it